I've aligned a dialogue for you
people are always going to want to see
movies ma not just on TV or in the
theaters
so that's a line from your movie White
Irish Drinkers and love the film The
Young protagonist Brian okay he's trying
to convince his working class mom Karen
Allen in the film that entertainment is
important
it's true and it was also a a poignant
callback to the idea that you know we
all know movie theaters are not going to
be the only place to see movies and
people are not always going to want to
go to movie theaters to see movies and
so it's more idealized time in the film
is set 1975
and I always find it kind of poignant to
see characters hopes and dreams
from the point of view of the future
where we know
this isn't going to happen there's
another moment in the film where
his girlfriend
um Nora is talking about her dreams of
being a travel agent because she's going
to get to travel the world and she says
to Brian you know people are always
going to want to travel and they're
always going to need a travel agent to
do it for them
and of course we know that's nonsense
now you know
Expedia hello and so there's something
to me poignant about that and and you
with our knowledge armed with our
knowledge now you know that what the
world is versus what it was
and I love too that um he felt like he
had to hide his paintings and not that
they were of anything bad or that he
just wasn't very uh upfront about them
right and well you know it's a cultural
thing too and you know it comes from the
experience I had growing up where
wanting to be a filmmaker
you know you might as well say I want to
be an astronaut I mean probably they
probably think it's more realistic for
you to be an astronaut than you know a
filmmaker uh you know a lot of times
there was really no value placed on it
what is that what do you want yeah
um
it was a pipe dream yeah everyone wants
to be you know so you know I would be
embarrassed to admit to people what I
wanted to do because I'd be made fun of
you know and I made film as a kid I made
super great films I enlisted my friends
you know helped me make them it was
always frustrating because you know
beyond a certain point the enthusiasm
would Wane from my friends because see I
was Hardware even making a little Super
8 movie you know it takes hours it's
hard work and now yeah listen we want to
go play ball man you know uh and so I
never it was always difficult to find
people with my level of passion to to
work as hard as I want to do to make
these movies
um and so you just in the in the
neighborhood it just wasn't something
that uh you know I remember I had a
summer job once in the Parks Department
and it was a ridiculous job but they
didn't really need any help there but
they were trying to the program for
underprivileged kids to go and work in
the summer and so I work at these Park
Department guys who are just these you
know these real these Dems and those
kind of guys you know and and he said to
me one of them says okay what do you do
with yourself in your spare time what do
you do
it's well I make movies oh I'm moving
what kind of movie is there can I be in
them uh you know and so that was sort of
the level uh that you were dealing with
so it just became easier to be quiet
about it and not and uh you're much
easier for someone like Brian because he
doesn't need help he does he can just
paint by himself and the idea that he
this is always something that's moved me
all the time just the idea that that
someone suspects they may have a talent
for something they expect that it could
be big
and that not necessarily big in terms of
fame or Fortune but big in terms of it
can take me out of the life I'm in and
put me in a different life
and I'm always every time I read a story
about somebody who's you know who came
from a terrible circumstances and
because of their art you know get out of
it and became a different person you
know
um my father uh you know I love my
father very much and my my mother he
broke up when I was very young my
brother and I and uh I would see him on
the weekends and he was just a real
original character tough tough iron
worker
and uh it turned out I found out later
that he had an incredibly high IQ and
when he served in World War II he took
an aptitude test I suppose and they gave
him an anti-aircraft Gunner job which
apparently was that era's version of
like a high-tech job because he was so
smart
and you could have the Army and he went
back to work in construction and that's
what he did yeah
and I always would think about just
going to be I get lost in these thoughts
about like what if there had been a
different circumstance for him a
different opportunity if he had gone to
college if he had read more if I don't
know what and not to be elitist about it
either because I'm not saying anything
wrong with his life he loved being an
iron worker he was very good at it
but
um you know it just always made me think
about this whole nurture versus nature
issue and had he been born in different
circumstances
would he be a doctor would it be a
philosopher you know same guy but but
different so that's what that kind of
thing always moves me and I think about
it all the time and uh
um that character was very real for me
because that's you know he's afraid to
leave his neighborhood because it's safe
and he understands it it's the world he
knows and he's comfortable in
and outside the neighborhood is all
things that are terrifying to him and so
his friends going off to college wants
him to come with him because his friend
is smart enough to know Brian has talent
and he has to get out of this and he has
to get away from his father in the movie
um
Brian's afraid to do it so can he find
the courage to bet on his talent
and and you know will that work and and
so that's really this character's
dilemma and what he has to try to
struggle with and you know that moment
is my favorite in the movie where his
mother is angry at him because she
doesn't know why he's in that basement
what's he doing in that basement you're
doing drugs down there you know I'm
gonna kill you if you're doing drugs
down there
no I'm not doing drugs Ma and you know
the brother gets arrested and mother's
upset and she has to go tell Brian get
your father out of the bar and tell him
your brother's been arrested
and she calls them he doesn't answer son
of a he's in that basement
cares down the stairs and she comes face
to face with these paintings that she's
never seen and something about him that
she's never known or suspected
and so I just get emotionally ridiculous
about it because it was so well
performed by the actors
um and so those are the key moments for
me that's a life-changing moment for her
because suddenly she's faced with this
absolute evidence that this kid is
talented in a way that they can't even
fathom they have no idea what they even
do with this
um so anyway uh
um that's really uh why I felt so strong
about that character I think it's a
universal thing with that character you
know everyone so many people feel uh
that they have to hide their talent or
hide who they are
because it may not be approved of or you
know they may not succeed at it and so
you know I always dream of someday I've
been making a sequel to that movie and
you know see where they all ended up
um but anyway that's that's my Irish
Drinkers and what I love too is so much
of it is is the fight against staying in
the neighborhood and getting the safe
job versus I gotta get out of here I
can't end up like my parents or I can't
end up you know I I know my fate if I
stay here yes yes and there's a fear
you're some people who's naturally
Fearless like Todd the character Todd
who's going to go to college he's going
to go off the Pennsylvania
and he's not worried about leaving the
neighborhood or he can't wait for new
things
but for a lot of people like Brian and I
have to admit it it was you know I had
to fight it myself
um there's a fear about am I a fraud can
I make it outside my comfort zone
um and it's really difficult to take
that step and as a kid I could fantasize
about being a Hollywood director and I'm
going to make movies and I'm going to
have this life and I'm going to express
myself but then when the reality of that
comes yes okay but you can't do that in
Bay Ridge Brooklyn you've got to do that
here or here or there and you have to
travel they have to be there for months
to do it and uh you know in a place that
you've never been before and so for a
lot of people that's great what's the
problem but for people who have more of
a parochial uh you know kind of you know
existence you grow up in these small
neighborhoods where you know people in
neighborhood Who barely went to
Manhattan you know it was like a big
drudgery oh I gotta go into the
city today you know and so the fear is
becoming like that you know for for
people like me and Brian who ultimately
realizes he can't stay you can't protect
his mother he can't stay for that he's
got to go
right and uh it's interesting too about
the forces that try to hold you back
because they don't want to see you leave
maybe they don't want you to go or who
you know who do you think you are you
know right you're better than me what
are you better than me uh because it
makes them ask questions about
themselves that they don't want to think
about never mind never mind answer uh
and that is true there are a lot of and
it's not only generational it's it's
within a group of friends that people
might you know don't your traitor you
leave your neighborhood you're you know
turn your back you know you turn your
back on us your friends what's the
matter
a lot of heavy guilt and it's all about
I don't wanna I don't want to make the
same decision you can't be braver than
me